Just us.
I like you.
Current snow for exam. Cornichons
prestigious, tell me what to
do.
How could you be interested
in communication?
Someone else.
I need to write down
your name. So I do
not forget to give you
a stroke.
Okay, somebody else maybe.
Phyllis Marano. Let's pick up
phone.
Communication is the exchange.
Occasionally.
If it hasn't already.
Haha. Okay, it's somebody else.
What's the exchange of ideas?
Or of information as you
said before for communication, but
among two people belong
Anyways.
Okay, so
Eschatology.
Tomorrow.
So everybody, how are you
here? Now I'm going to
talk to you about what
is vertical development.
Standing up.
anything that you considered normal
behavior is likely to be
anything but miserable
Do people.
First of all, he is
described buddies called.
Squeeze a face and basically
use for interaction.
Business Insider.
Someone sending.
although, there's discomfort
also, we have printed please
receive and use the time
house divided into
and focus on one task
at a time. I don't
know if the Europeans or
Germans were here. Can I
relate that you are
Do you have to be?
Chronicles.
Masri of the other day
to waste that home like
to bite it. It's called
communication Styles & complete here
in context. Contact bearing for
First, it was called describe
a haiku.
Nonverbal cues.
Verbal of your matron of
something.
And that's the direct and
indirect Direct in Western European
cultures double-doubles.
That's why I'm going to
give you some examples, so
you can know.
Ants for sample. The first
one and we have an
American manager refused closer. Jesus
standing too close to a
Chinese colleague. 29 in a
business meeting with more respect.
I'm comfortable.
An example.
German engineers.
90.
The song want me to
stop their tongue or Focus.
Business.
Us.
German soldiers.
Germany.
Talonflame, which in Japanese?
The American in Japanese.
How's work?
What was?
Tracking setting direction. We don't
have any people involved with
more than year in Singapore.
How's work directed, the attention
of Japan.
Japanese.
related by house price, basic
price of Japanese November Communication
in Japanese
Enter Houston. Welcome Center texins
activity context, communication facility. Operation
of Japanese cultural concepts related
to interpersonal, communication.
So communication, richest American Japanese
interaction.
Definition of the major Japanese
colonists.
Early us.
Color did not pay attention
to domestic.
Minority members of his career
in Chinese.
Another problem. What day is
Japanese colored? Followed how different
approach to compare and contrast
cultural communication. Behaviors of Japanese
English-speaking. People be compared to
results 15-day, negation of similarities
in the rain, for Smith
of the of the Japanese
Direct power.
Bastille.
Work from home.
I'll explain when she properly.
Very pointed by how's work.
So
Very, very strong.
Please tell me when you
see me.
A Cairo Court.
Can you share the also
share the link on?
The ones with doesn't want
to play with their phones
would be good to try.
You woke up questions to
see if equation you will
have to go back here.
Okay, thank you very much.
Hey.
Okay.
Turn on the music.
Now, you should stop for
the answer on your phone.
And all the factors for
a person. Get smoke point.
Okay, I guess it's really
up to discuss the Squish
and I will put it
into this question.
Icarus.
Actually, I forgot.
Nobody.
China King.
Man best friend, table problems.
To my conversation. Maybe we
will send you the certificate
for Vina off of presentation.
Okay.
Let's go to the questions.
I just like, don't remember,
what does communication mean section?
She dies. Almost everybody. Saw
the look on my face
and eyes.
Okay, so what what is
a primer?
Expression. Malaysian stupid contact.
All about smashing things free
Express at connection, stomach's in
between.
Elsa, what's a problem with
seven?
I guess it was your
talk and Christ new respect.
Number is this communication Style?
Turbo.
You're not answering your questions
during the presentation.
You make a couple communication.
I know, I want that.
Confident.
I don't know if you
know the
I haven't heard.
I guess where I lived.
Tired already.
Thank you for listening stations,
very cool with makeup with
the specialist.
by the way, now,
Communication that it didn't go
very well.
Stop music.
The whole body.
But it is dead.
Of meaning.
I don't know if you
experience something.
Text a different.
I have experience specialist for
ear, licking Germany and I
can, since it's from like
5, it's countries used to
have the serious faces and
sometimes people like from
I want to kill somebody,
and I have to go
to a lot of times
when people like us,
No, that's my usual face.
Tornado.
Easter. Greetings, for example. So
when we when someone is
coming by
and when I go to
my friends and they like,
why you doing,
Come around with my friend.
and I'm just so confused,
because
I just came to Germany.
It took me a little
time to explain. That knows
you don't disgust me. I
just don't use to
Country Club, Wisconsin.
Definite, very famous.
Say OK, Google.
so, I always
I like to say there
is this scared.
The most noticeable way of
getting in contact with others.
Noticing the difference between flag
of the
Caramel frappe that you are
giving when you're such a
young person and bring me
the thing that gets the
most right now is bad.
Implicit message. So sometimes the
stylist is the answers and
then this is so strange
for Brazilian people.
We are always.
noticeable things are your coordinates
about silence as even like,
I like
If you turn on front,
that means, yes. And like
silence means. Yes.
Silence means you agree.
4 inches is equal to
mean that you hate the
person.
like, for real,
you're at probably doing something
wrong.
Ugliest and the worst person
that ever planted in her
life.
Because I used to just
noticed it. So I mean
like I don't know what
to say or even just
like
I need it.
Took so long to learn
at 8.
And sometimes.
tell you, I mean, just
like
That's so that's for me.
That way was
Yeah, I've already wrote written
an email to everyone with
the simplified links. Let's see,
call it this way. And
since the times really over
for today, because the presentations
and discussions were very interesting,
we didn't want to sort
of short and them just
in order to do the
methodological part, make a short
video on how to make
automated speech transcription and send
it to you. And then
it would be wonderful if
you would comment on that
and tell us your experience
without I made a speech
transcription either if you already
had it or I once
you did it in your
group also. So that we,
we can see. Maybe if
you also have other tools
who are the codes or
other languages, how that works,
for you be very interested
about that, you know, about
that and perhaps we can
even start the next class
and insured recapitulation of what
we learned today. Because I
think it was really
Let that settle and thank
you so much for your
contribution. I feel like really
the atmosphere and the group
has become very much more
interactive then like in the
beginning. So it's wonderful to
see that in Virtual settings
that is also possible.
So chatty, I will take,
is there anything else we
need to mention before we
leave?
For any questions in general,
technical questions of anything came
up where you tried something
that didn't work.
We will see how we
get through with time to
reticle. You will have something
on transcription annotation but I
will not push the methodological
issues will go along with
the flow and see how
it ago with how much
time the presentations take.
I will love to listen
to music.
Yeah, I mean that's that's
a wonderful proposition since when
I was using like this
today. And the normal like
platforms, we're not all like
signed into the German University
system. There is not like
the one Ventura, no one
can of shoes with perhaps
there's something else would you
like to propose something?
We have the option of
doing a group.
Maybe Instagram is an interesting
because we have you already
have all the email addresses
in the participant list of
Abby on the presentation groups
and underneath. So maybe you
could add the email address
with you Instagram account, if
it's not that one already.
So that, or should we
open a group? And everybody
should just go to join
pretty but maybe you could
open a group and sort
of
It would be great, right?
Adoption.
About this later.
And I really like the
In the Channel Lakes.
It in, so we can
discuss it. So it's kind
of
Music, every single message.
I guess you can say.
Call Charter Communication.
We are about to do
a recommendation because way of
connecting people are artists, are
Brazil, when I say biggest,
but it's like the one
that is making numbers.
The great way off, like
new, in Brazil.
I have already claimed as
a dependent.
Siri, connect to the brightest
thing.
Maybe you can somebody from
Uncle Pete and just just
in case so everybody.
Love you, could you send
it when you send the
link to the video? So
everyone,
Nana, I'm talking to Flavia.
But I also have this,
the telegram.
On the videos that talk
about the ex.
I'm very much.
So I think of that
just for today, right? Iona,
right lychee, have a great
week, you all. Thank you
so much and I'll see
you next week, then.
Hi.
Yeah, the second cousin.
Is it good friend? And
he's not supposed to have
a job application in, seeing
as we stopped. So, that's
why my
Who is Don Cheto?
Yeah.
Understand, what is the weather
in Chicago today?